for 20 days hundreds of indigenous
embera have been living in tents and
under plastic sheets in bogota's
national park located in the city center
like most here arnold and his family
were displaced from their village in
western colombia a year ago after being
caught in the crossfire of rising
violence between armed groups in the
military
at first they received housing
assistance and covet 19 subsidies but
the relief package ran out in september
and they've ended up here saying they
have nowhere else to go
we can't feed ourselves some eat some
don't and the winter is hard here if we
had a safe way to go back we would but
if we can't then we need help
the camp conditions are dire five kids
have ended up sick in intensive care
units this week
some 1 500 in beta are currently
homeless in the city few speak spanish a
thousand have been relocated to a camp
outside bogota with basic amenities city
authorities agree it's not ideal but
it's all they can offer
law is subsidies can't be given
indefinitely by the district they had an
expiration for the pandemic and the
victims law which is a national entity
should begin a reparations process we
are waiting for that to happen and
hopefully they will also be able to
return home
on friday the capitol police issued an
order of eviction giving authorities 48
hours to try and convince the embera to
voluntarily move to a different camp on
the outskirts of bogota before forcibly
removing them
a previous attempt this week to conduct
a pre-removal census ended in scuffles
2020 was the most violent year in more
than a decade in colombia amid
continuing conflict in remote areas many
more indigenous people could be forced
to resettle in cities like bogota in
coming months
thousands of indigenous people have had
to seek refuge in cities as a result of
the violence the war and the armed
groups operating in their territories
they are being sacked by those who want
to take the gold the wood and the other
resources all they want is to be able to
go back but unfortunately there is no
real return policy
a complicated humanitarian crisis that
critics say will only worsen unless its
root causes are addressed alessandra
piety al jazeera bogota